字幕: Akiko Kamio
校正: Yumika Amano
石屋製菓ですね　昭和22年
私の祖父である
石水幸安が創業致しました
この『しあわせをつくるお菓子』
という言葉なんですけれども
これは 私が２年前　2013年にですね
私が社長に就任したときに
掲げた言葉です
私の祖父の石水幸安の名前の「ゆき」が
「幸せ」っていう漢字なんですね
「つくる」っていう字はですね
私の名前が石水創 なんですけれども
「はじめ」が創造の「創」ですね
という形になっております
この言葉ができた後に
気づいた事なんですけれども
これを父である会長にですね
この『しあわせをつくるお菓子』
という言葉を伝えると
「なんで俺の名前が入ってないんだ」
というふうに(笑)
まぁ そういう会社です(笑)
私1982年3月30日
末っ子、長男、姉が２人いるんですけれど
将来の後取り息子として生まれました
周りからも言われるんですよね
「将来はお菓子屋の社長だね」
というふうに言われます
私自身もお菓子屋の社長に
なるものだと思っていましたし
それが当然のことと思っておりました
その「後を継ぐ」ということはですね
色々なシチュエーションがあると
思うんですけれども
親が社長だとですね
大学を卒業したタイミングで後を継ごうかな
と思う人もいると思います
または 「継ぎたくない」から
「継ぐ」に変わる場合もあると思います
もしくは親が何か病気をした時に
予期せぬタイミングで自分の会社に戻る
というパターンもあると思います
私の場合は物心ついた時から
お菓子屋の社長になるのが夢でした
なぜ 物心ついた時から
お菓子屋さんの社長になるのが
夢だったのかなと考えるとですね
当然 周りからも「社長だね」って
言われるのはあるんですけれども
やはり父の影響がものすごく大きいです
父は私が小さい頃から
東区にある工場
今ほど大きくないんですけれども
その工場によく連れて行ってくれました
その中で 工場に行くと
パートさんが「これ食べな」ということで
お菓子をすごく一杯もらえるんですよね
なのでまた工場に行きたい
という様な理由で
よく工場には行ってたんですけれども
そういった事があったりしました
あとは 家に帰ったときも
私の父はよく仕事の話をしてくれるんですよね
仕事の話というのはお菓子の話です
こんな新商品できたら
おもしろいだろうとかですね
またはですね
今は西区にある白い恋人パーク
あそこの図面ですとか絵を持ってきて
「こういうのできたら喜んでもらえるだろう」
とかですね
そういう話をしてくれたので
仕事は楽しいものだと
子供の頃は思っていました
小学校の卒業式の時も
「僕は将来有名なお菓子屋の社長になって
人々が美味しいと言ってくれるような
お菓子をいっぱいつくりたいです 」
と宣言しました
日本にはですね現在法人企業は250万社ある
と言われています
その内99.7%が中小企業で
97%が同族系です
私もファミリー企業 父が社長でしたので
ファミリー企業になるんですけれども
250万社 会社があるということは
250万通りの社長、経営者がいる
という事になります
勿論 自分で会社を起こす
ベンチャー企業の社長さんもいるでしょうし
もしくはサラリーマン社長もいると思います
またあるいは ずっとその会社にいる
生え抜き社長さんもいると思いますし
私の場合は後継者社長という形になります
親が社長なのだから 継ぐのが当たり前
ずっとそういう風に思っておりました
よく 親が社長だとボンボンという風に
言われることが多いんですね
私もよく言われたんですけど
ボンボン 確かに
何不自由ない暮らしをして来ましたので
ボンボンというのは一部では
当てはまるとは思うんですけども
それに対する反骨心みたいなものも
一部ではありました
子供の頃 どちらかと言うと
私は引っ込み思案な性格で
何をするにもトライをする
ことをあまりしなかったです
授業中とかも こう手を挙げて
発言するなんてことはしなかったですし
まさか私がこうやって
TEDxSapporoに出させていただける
また 出ようと思うとは
考えてもいなかったです
私の父は ずっとスキーのインストラクターを
しておりまして
母も実はスキーの生徒でした
そういう関係もあって 私自身も小さい頃から
ずっとスキーをしておりました
裏に山があって
今はもうスキー場ではないんですけれども
荒井山という山があったんですね
その山に玄関を降りて スキーの板を履いて
滑ってリフト乗り場まで行くみたいな
そういった環境だったんですけれども
そういった中で育ちました
高校も大学もスキー推薦で進学したんですが
大学の寮がこれまた 写真にもあるんですけど
ゴミ屋敷みたいなところでして(笑)
一年生の時は４畳半２人部屋クーラーなし
という生活をずっとしておりました
一年生が 朝ご飯も夜ご飯も作ります
朝５時に起きて朝練をするという様な
過酷な環境ですね
東洋大学は箱根駅伝ですごく
今有名ですけれども
埼玉にあるんですね
埼玉って日本で一番暑い地域とも
言われてますけれども
札幌でずっと生まれ育った関係で
埼玉の夏がもう耐えられなくて
おまけにクーラーがなくて
２人部屋で扇風機１台ですから
その角度を決めるのに
すごく喧嘩したこともありました
恐らく今 大学一年生の時が一番今の為
になっているのではないかと思います
一方でですね大学３年生になると
もう全部付くんですよね 食事もつきますし
そうなるとスキーの成績も
頭打ちになっていったので
引きこもり時代に入ってしまいます
もう何もしないんですね
大学に行って帰ってきたら
寮に戻ってきて 練習にも行かないで
ずっと引きこもっていました
部屋でずっとテレビゲームしたりですとか
DVDで映画を見たりですとか
そういう生活を一年間ずっとしていました
そうなると一年経った時に
何も残っていないことに気がつくんですよね
自分の為に何もなっていないなと
すごく楽なんですけど
引きこもりというのは すごく楽なんですが
人とも触れあうことはないですし
ストレスも感じないので
すごく楽なんですけれども
何も残っていないことに気がつきました
それに気づかせてくれたのが
実は その一年生の時の同部屋で
その当時ですね
４年生のキャプテンをやっていた友人でした
彼からある言葉を言われたんですね
スキーというのは非常に
お金がかかるスポーツです
スキーの板も買わないといけないですし
リフト券もそうですし
合宿に行くにも
１ヶ月間宿泊費も払わないといけない
すごくお金のかかるスポーツなんだけれども
「創は」私の名前は「創」なんですが
「創は そういった親の気持ち 感謝の気持ちとか
全く考えてないだろ」という風に
言われたんですよね
「ボンボンだから分からないだろ」
みたいな
その時 こうハッとしたんですね
親の後を継いで 外に発信する
（社長に）なるという夢は言っていても
その為の努力を何もしてこなかった
ということに気づきました
それ以来は私はもう
なんでもチャレンジするようになりました
失敗してもいいや と
自分が出来ないかもしれないな
というリミットを超えるような
チャレンジを必ずやろうと
なんでもトライするようになりました
それが親の後を継ぐ 引き継ぐ
ということだと気づきました
引きこもっていては何も残りません
石屋製菓に就職して最初は修業時代ですね
製造の 現場の方に入りました
昼間はお菓子の製造をしてですね
夜はお菓子の専門学校に通いました
また イギリス、スイスの方に
語学とチョコレートの留学もさせてもらいました
このまま順調に社長になるんだろうなと
自分の中では思っていたんですが
ある事件が起こります
2007年ですね8月15日
ちょうどお盆の時期
お盆というと北海道観光が
すごい一番ピークの時なんですよね
そこに『白い恋人』賞味期限改ざん
という重大な出来事が起こってしまいます
その時に もしかしたら会社が倒産してしまう
かもしれないという恐怖に陥りました
当時は１日に８万件くらい
全国のお客様から電話がかかってきました
そのうち対応できたのが400件ですね
ほとんど対応出来ない パニックの状態でした
もうお客様からは当然ですね
『白い恋人』を結婚式の引き出物に使ってしまった
どうしてくれる とかですね
もしくは 企業のお中元で
企業の偉い社長さんに
プレゼントで贈ってしまった
どうしてくれる ですとか
もう本当にどうしようもならないような
状況でした
その時気づいたのは 私はお菓子を作っていると
思ったんですけれども
ただのお菓子ではなかったんですね
白い恋人というのはお菓子ではなくて
白い恋人というのはなんでしょう
北海道に行った証ですとか 思い出ですとか
日頃お世話になった方への
感謝の気持ちですとか
そういったものを作っているんだと
再認識しました
その後再開しても
一度ブランドに傷がついてしまったお菓子を
また消費者の方が選んでくれるだろうか
というのはすごく半信半疑でした
そして その３ヶ月後ですね
お盆の時期の３ヶ月後
8月15日でしたから　11月の23日ですね
今でも忘れないんですけれども
販売を再開致しました
その時にある現象が起こったんですね
白い恋人っていうのは本来ですね
お土産菓子ですので 道外の方が
買うケースがすごく多いんですけれども
その時は実は北海道の方が
応援してくれたんですよね
白い恋人応援しよう
石屋製菓ガンバレということで
すごく応援してくれました
その時に私にとっての
「しあわせをつくる」 ということは
北海道の方に恩返しをすることだと
考えるようになりました
これは本当に大きな転機でした
当然会社にとっても
実は大きな機会になりました
ここで「危機」を「機会」というのは
もしかしたら語弊があるのかもしれないです
会社として企業としては当然危機ですし
重大なコンプライアンス違反を犯した
これはもう罰せられるべきものだと思います
ただ そこで働いている従業員
またはその組織にとっては
物凄くいい機会だったんですね
それは何かというと
全員が同じ目標に向かって
進むことができたんです
その目標は何か
安心・安全 とコンプライアンスです
また再開してもお客様が戻ってくるかどうか
分からない中で従業員一致団結して
とにかく安心・安全 と コンプライアンスを
これを合い言葉にして頑張ることができた
これは凄く大きいです
現在不祥事のときを経験している従業員は
実はもう半分くらいになっています
ところが安心・安全とコンプライアンスというのは
企業の文化となって今もなお残っておりますし
これからも風化させてはいけない
と思っております
私もこの不祥事が起こってから
やはりお菓子のことだけを勉強していては
ダメだという風に感じまして
2011年から小樽商科大学の
ビジネススクールに通い始めました
そこで本当に何事にも
トライをするようになりまして
おそらくこのビジネススクールに
通っていなければ
今ここで私がこういうお話しをする事も
なかったと思います
ここで得たのは本当に最高の仲間ですし
やはり経営の基礎知識を学んだ
一通り学んだことでもあります
そして過酷な課題を全てクリアしたという
自信にもなりました
自分への自信にもなりました
私は本来体育会系ですので
実は今年からトライアスロンですとか
始めるようになりました
文系ですか理系ですかと言われると
私は必ず体育会系ですと
答えるんですけれども(笑)
トライアスロンを始めています
後は自転車ですね
この前も富良野で112キロ走ってきました
後はスキー
これはもうずっと小さい頃からやっていますし
実は私の家族は娘
今三姉妹 三人娘がいるんですけれども
3人ともスキーを始めております
あと フットサルですね
これは社内でチームを作って
企業対抗戦という形でやっております
いろいろなことに本当にトライをしております
北海道
私にとっての北海道なんですけれども
本当に大好きなんです
日本全国 世界にもいろいろ
社長になって行く機会が
多くなったんですけれども
改めて北海道っていいところだな
と思います
すごく自然もいいですし　食事も美味しいです
程よく都会で 程よく田舎ですよね
そういう環境が本当に大好きです
そして人も優しい　そういう北海道の魅力を
どうすれば発信できるかなということを考える
そしてそれを実行するということも
大切な事かなと考えております
これは一つの例なんですけれども
去年イギリスに行ってきました
社長賞という賞があって社員と一緒に
イギリスに行ってきたんですけれども
実はイギリス ロンドンですね
ロンドンはロンドンオリンピックが
終わってからの方が
観光客が増えているんですよね
それは何故なんだろうと考えたら
非常に観光客に優しいんですよね
これは地下鉄のタッチパネル
なんですけれども
20カ国語ぐらい対応している
ようなんですね
チケット売り場ですね
これで日本語を押すと
全部日本語で説明書きがでます
ワンデーパスみたいなものを ピッと押すと
地下鉄もバスも市電も全部
乗れるようになります
さらにその地下鉄 バス タクシー等に乗ると
全部Wi-Fi フリーですね
さらにそのWi-Fiで繋ぐと まず最初に
日本語で観光案内がでるんですよね
そこまでハード面が整備されています
素晴らしい街です
一方 ソフト面
今年のゴールデンウィーク前に
金沢に行ってきました
北陸新幹線が通りまして
今すごく注目されていますけれども
駅を降りて地図を広げると
まっさきに市民の方が
声を掛けてくれるんですよね
どちらに行かれるんですか？
みたいに声を掛けてくれます
私はその中で「兼六園に行きたいんです」
と言ったらですね
そのバス停の乗り場まで行って
何番出口に行って
こうやって行けば行けますよと
説明を凄く丁寧にしてくれました
町並みも凄く綺麗ですね
去年まではこの金沢の
旧市街と言われている所は
ほとんどテナントさんが
入ってなかったみたいなんですよね
ところが今年に入ってからですね
カフェですとか飲食店ですとか
お土産屋さんですとか ずらっと並んで
もう金沢は去年の金沢とは別の街ですよと
地元の方が言っていました
そういう意味では来年
函館に函館新幹線が通りますので
本当に今から北海道は準備をしていかないと
函館だけのことではないと思います
北海道全部でやはり盛り上げていかなければ
いけないことかなと思います
一方 私の夢でもあるんですけれども
これはハーシーチョコレートワールドと言う
アメリカのフィラデルフィアにある
施設なんですよね
ここに 今から５年位前に
私も行った事があるんですけれども
ここは一つのお菓子の街が
出来上がっているんですよね
この写真を見て頂きますと
街（灯）柱がキスチョコっていう
ハーシーのチョコレートのお菓子で有名な
チョコになっていたりですとか
住所もカカオアベニューとかですね
チョコレートストリートとかですね
全てお菓子にまつわるような
街になっております
その街 ハーシーがフィラデルフィアの一角に
出来たことによって
こういう （ハーシーの）アミューズメント
パークも出来てしまいました
更には大学もあります
ハーシーユニバーシティー
大学もできたりとか
その大学に付随して
アメリカンフットボールの
大きいスタジアムが出来たりですとか
一つのお菓子屋さんが地域を作ってしまった
街を作ってしまった
これは本当に究極かなという風に思います
最後にですね子供達に夢を伝える
ということなんですが
10年以上も前にやっている
一日工場長というイベントで
小学生に夢のお菓子を絵に描いてもらって
当社のパティシエがそれを実現するという
イベントなんですよね
それに選ばれた一人の小学生なんですけれども
彼は今どうしているかというと
当社の社員になっております
（拍手)
10年後に一日工場長が帰ってきた
ということで
今現在 新工場を作るプロジェクトチームの
中核を担ってもらっています
もう一つ
自分の子供にはどうだろうかと
私自身 父から凄く夢を与えてもらったので
自分の子供にもその夢を
与えられているだろうかと
実際 家に帰ったときに完全オフ状態なので
靴下も一人で脱げないような
それぐらいオフの状態なんですけれども
自分の子供に対してはどうかな
と考えていたんですよね
そうしたら先月ですね
うちの娘が誕生日だったんですね
幼稚園の先生からインタビューを受ける中で
将来の夢は何ですかと
先生から聞かれたそうなんですよね
うちの娘がですね
「白い恋人パークの社長さん」
ということで
(拍手)
ちゃんと家では伝えられては
いないですけれども
ちゃんと親父の背中を見て
育ってくれているのかなという風に
嬉しくも感じました
本日は ご清聴どうも
ありがとうございました
(拍手)